this is the number one save that money
story of the week this needs to be a new
thing i saved that money story of the
week the number one and it has to do
with the guy they call salt bay oh you
familiar with this guy oh saltbae oh
sope a little bit of a little bit of
this a little bit a little bit of this a
little bit you know about this yeah this
guy's made millions from this
right here not a fan no wait to hear
these prices you let me know if you're a
fan after this yeah so people can't
believe
how much freaking salt bae is charging
for steaks at his new london restaurant
okay so turkish chef saltpei
his real name is nusret
wait a minute yes he's not called sopa
in real life
he's like a real life meme just like
that this is him that's him so he
sprinkles his you know salt over his
juicy steaks he's feeding people with
basically machetes have you seen this
stuff yeah i don't yeah get a look at
him get a look at him come on there he
is there he is david i want to see the
faces god look at this i want to see
this guy
he's sprinkling
all this so basically the stars showed
up in london for this new restaurant
opening david beckham was there leonardo
dicaprio was there
supermodel extraordinaire naobi campbell
was there and they were all eating and
gobbling up some of this expensive food
but wait till you hear the prices
of this food jesus wait till you hear
the markup
on what salt bae is charging to eat at
his restaurant so you know they said
that saltpe never does interviews
there's a reason why do you know the
reason why because there's no way he's
gonna be able to defend these prices
no freaking way so here's some items on
the menu let's start with the big dog of
them all
the gold wrapped giant tomahawk steak
you know how much for steak how much 860
bucks
for a steak no way okay adam okay let me
ask you have you ever had a steak from
there from salt-based steak no
would you no i'm not spending 800 not
even for like the store like i had it
and it sucks let me tell you something
you know what tastes better than 860
dollar steak paying a couple weeks of
rent yeah yeah okay or making your car
payment and car insurance for the month
that takes that tastes better than 860
dollar freaking steak
okay that steak better be able to teach
my kids how to read if it's gonna cost
this much i don't even have kids
860 bucks for steak yeah okay it's
aggressive do you want me to keep going
down the menu uh you please okay please
i almost don't how much did you think a
hamburger is oh a freaking burger how
much
400 bucks
yeah for a burger 135 dollars for a
burger okay if i'm spending 135 on a
burger you better give me a cow
to go
all right
so it's ridiculous all right so that's
the ketchup on that sir yes
they charge uh three dollars just for
ketchup
you know they're thick okay
french fries how much are french fries i
don't know 14
for french fries these french fries for
14 bucks better help me speak french
okay
after eating these freaking french fries
sweet corn you ever had these appetizers
sweet corn it's like mashed up corn you
know how much this is sixteen dollars
sixteen dollars for a little little
thing
this corn better be sweet they better
say nice things to me that compliment my
outfit tell me i'm looking good today
all right
take that sweet corn and put in your
freaking man bun saltpe
okay it's a half a take a gas right
there
16 you know how much of coca hey can i
get a coke yeah cool with my 850 steak
how much do you think a coke is i can't
what come on what twenty twelve bucks
bro oh my god coke
coke actually cost a dollar it's eleven
dollars just to hang out with
because he doesn't bring it to you
though it's not him
i've heard stories of people that look
like him
like right she's a guy with a
glasses ponytail and he comes and he
serves it to you and it's unbelievable
it doesn't say anything you're just no
let me tell you and then this last one
it was just like okay i like what okay
red bull how much is a red bullet
just a red bull for things that already
how much is a red bull
red bull is like three dollars fifteen
dollars for a red bull why
this red bull if they bring me a 15 i
better actually grow wings okay
and i better fly home afterwards with a
red bull like this okay it gives you
wings
so oh my god saltbae gives doing so he's
got locations all around the world so
you can get robbed by salt bay in new
york miami dubai
istanbul and now
london
look my god yes this is what's going on
excessiveness of these prices to eat
to to have a man sprinkle salt and stab
you to death almost with a with a knife
as he feeds you
steak in your mouth 860 steak so there's
gonna be foodies out there
okay that is gonna argue it's not the
price of the meal it's i'm actually
really excited about it yes i know it's
not the price of the meal it's about the
experience okay it's about the company
you're with it's about the memories that
you create what do you think about that
no i yeah i no i hate it the memories
the only memory i'm gonna have is the
time that salt bay emptied my bank
account okay
exactly ridiculous yeah i want that
soft-based restaurant how are you doing
i'm homeless now yeah yeah it was great
i just by the way i can't pay my habit
by the way uh my car broke down i can't
afford gas i can't pay my rent this
month but damn that eight hundred dollar
steak was tasty exactly no base was
great man i just got out uh funny that
you have to pick me up though i gave him
my car
a box together yeah i had to i'm
cleaning dishes in the back because i
couldn't pay the 1200
bill for a table of two you picked me up
in two hours unfricking believable yeah
anyway
i've had a situation like this where um
you know i'm not a foodie okay i like i
i've got levels yeah that's so true i've
got levels of what i'm willing to spend
money on yeah
three different levels if i'm by myself
like it's like all right going home dude
like i'll cook at home
i'm not spending money to go order out
just like
nothing right okay 10 20 bucks max
for me just to have a meal i'm not
spending money
a bunch of my boys are like oh we're
doing guys dinner once a month they get
they go to the nicest restaurants i'm
like look if i'm having dinner with my
boys
the homies yeah me the boys robin hood
you me the dude we'll go to a
sports bar okay we'll get chicken wings
we'll hang out 50 bucks max yeah okay
like we go to these fancy sushi
restaurants salt bay's restaurant i'm
spending 200 bucks to sit around with my
boys i'm good adam you yeah me
the boys salt bank
of that i'm out
now the only time i actually will spend
money and like treat myself is with a
girl he's in front of her
if i'm going on a date we'll go to a
nice restaurant there's cool there's two
of us bottle of wine what have you
that's cool there's different levels to
this uber lux uber lux
willing too so understand how much money
like i talked about your big three
expenses yeah housing transportation
food and beverage food and beverage is
the part that where people don't know
how much money they're freaking spending
because salt bae just spent just ripped
your ass off okay just got robbed by
salt
all we talk is bay
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken